unlike most Call of Duty games black ops
4 doesn't possess the typical campaign
instead in its place our minor cutscenes
brief exchanges and audio segments
throughout this video I'll be discussing
those elements in relation to woods and
Mason to give you a breakdown of their
overall story as well as what this means
for the series as a whole there will be
heavy spoilers and may be worth skipping
this video for now if you're yet to
complete the game without the way I'm
definition and I play the game so you
don't have to at the ending of Call of
to II woods and Mason's story culminates
in an exchange between the two via an
audio segment in order to fully
understand the meaning behind there we
must first breakdown Savannah's overall
plan project blackout Savannah is
Mason's granddaughter and is just an
all-round bad egg project blackout
itself is a process in which highly
repeatable dead soldiers are cloned and
trained to be a blackops level this
training takes place in a ground called
blackout hence project blackout these
soldiers are referred to as archetypes
and it's revealed that woods in Mason
are among their ranks
Savannah's sister Jessica is on to this
plan and thus Savannah needs her killed
in the end it turns out that Woods has
been working with Savannah in order to
kill Jessica woods has been using the
brainwashing techniques from black ops
in order to control Mason and this is
why we hear an audio file called Mason's
ladder in which woods reads the numbers
out loud to the character in the final
exchange between the two Woods tells
Mason it was you in a box it always was
this is in order to make him more
compliant it refers to the scene in
black ops 2 where Mason and Hudson
rescue woods from a shipping container
and nurse tricks Mason into believing
that would saved his life the final
cutscene takes place in the asylum area
black out lap which adds a lot of weight
to the theory that both Woods and Mason
now exist in project blackout players
that journey to the same spot and
blackout confined a note written by
Mason showing the faces of the
specialists with their names written
underneath woods Mason
Menendez and Rezanov are all available
characters and have been confirmed to be
archetypes in project black out there
also exists a lot of evidence to support
the theory that Savannah is in fact an
archetype herself in the cutscene I
slash the lamb in you letting their
black blood stream we can clearly see
another person sitting next to Savannah
on her bed this person looks identical
to her and could be her archetype
there's a wealth of Easter eggs
currently developing in regards to the
game and there's a great thread on
reddit which has been regularly updated
with new developments that I will link
to in the description of this video it
massively helped putting this video
together and there's still a lot to
uncover so make sure you check that out
at the end of this video so what are
your thoughts on the development story
of black ops 4 do you enjoy piecing
together the tidbits of information
we've been given or would you prefer an
overall linear narrative as I mentioned
there are constantly evolving pieces of
information so if I've missed anything
or something's changed make sure to
leave the updates in the comments this
is a channel for the hardcore players
who are heavy into games so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
you
[Music]